From the myths of the Middle Ages, to fantasy
novels, to popular television shows with horrible
last seasons, there is one mystical creature
that has stood the test of time again and
again.
For almost as long as human beings have gathered
together and shared stories, the imaginations
of countless generations have been captivated
by the same image.
An enormous winged reptile, soaring through
the skies, sometimes depicted as a wise, noble
creature, and other times feared as it breathes
fire down upon its foes.
For as long as there have been people to tell
them, there have always been tales of dragons,
be they benevolent or monstrous.
But these are just stories, aren’t they?
But surely a legend does not survive for so
many centuries without a reason.
And with all the other myths and ancient folklore
that the SCP Foundation has found to be true,
who’s to say that there aren’t still dragons
somewhere up in the mountains?
SCP-3844 was one such creature.
First discovered in 1906, a creature exactly
like the legends described was found to be
living in the Dolomites, a mountain range
located in north eastern Italy.
One of the first to see it was a man named
Doctor Lester Fegmont, and he recounted his
findings to a friend, Frederick, in a letter
that the SCP Foundation keeps on file.
This document is one of the first recorded
sightings of SCP-3844, and details how Lester
eventually came face to face with the winged
beast of legend.
Having spotted something that they instantly
recognized as a dragon, Lester, his associate,
Galviston, and a guide traversed the slopes
of the Dolomite Mountains to find where the
creature had made its home.
According to the description of the beast
in Lester’s letter, “It soared over one
peak, let out a low roar that loosened snow
from the mountainside, and then dived out
of sight.
Its wings blocked out the sun like a cloud
passing overhead.
I wish the whole lab could have seen it.”
After two hours, the group arrived at the
dragon’s cavern.
From the way Lester described it, the place
was like the lair of Smaug, the dragon famously
featured in J.R.R.
Tolkien’s The Hobbit.
The cave was filled to the brim with treasure,
and seemed to stretch on deeper into the mountain
than the supplies they’d brought with them
would allow them to explore.
But there was no sign of the creature they
had seen flying overhead.
Giving up on their search, the group began
to leave the treasure-filled cave, preparing
to head back down out of the mountains the
way they had come.
But then, they heard the roar.
Still in the dragon’s lair, Lester had no
idea if the sound had come from in front or
behind, until they saw the creature outside
the cave’s entrance.
Lester was terrified, but then he realized
something: the dragon wasn’t trying to threaten
the men, he was welcoming the intrepid trio
as its guests.
SCP-3844 apparently spoke very eloquently
to the group, sounding like quite the gentleman
according to Lester.
It seemed to possess some sort of shape shifting
ability, as the letter describes the creature
“changed its form to resemble a young man
to make us feel more relaxed.”
The dragon referred to the group as “a new
age of knights” and seemed to be very up
to speed on the current affairs of 1906.
What followed was a lengthy negotiation between
Lester and SCP-3844, agreeing on terms that
would keep the dragon confined to the Dolomite
Mountain range and away from the prying eyes
of the public.
It seemed that the group had been sent in
to deal with SCP-3844 on behalf of Italian
officials.
In his letter, Lester mentioned his uncertainty
in placing his trust in the creature, hoping
not to be double crossed, and transcribed
the conditions that were agreed upon.
The dragon, whose name was apparently Tharnock,
but was also referred to as ‘The Anomaly’,
was to limit the amount of times it ventured
out of its cave to only once per day, and
keep its flights within the area of the Dolomites.
Tharnock was also advised to refrain from
roaring or vocalizing whenever it left its
lair.
In return, Lester and his Anomaly Investigation
Foundation would send an ambassador to confer
with the dragon once a week, and punish anyone
who attempted to steal any valuable artefacts
from the creature’s hoard of treasure.
Lastly, the Nation of Italy swore to encourage
its citizens to avoid traveling to the Dolomite
Mountains, and would publicly discredit any
eyewitness reports, denying Tharnock’s existence.
Many years passed, and Doctor Lester Fegmont
rose through the ranks of the SCP Foundation,
eventually becoming known as O5-2, a member
of the infamous O5 Council.
SCP-3844 was kept confined to the same area
within the Dolomites, but the methods of keeping
it there began to change.
The Foundation set up a perimeter around the
area, keeping civilians from entry.
They installed anti-aircraft artillery near
the cave where Tharnock was first found, to
be used against the dragon in the event of
a full scale containment breach.
Researchers were sent in to study the creature,
taking temperature and radiation readings,
testing SCP-3844’s IQ and providing it with
magazines on science, nature, and current
affairs as reading material.
The Foundation learned that SCP-3844, much
like the dragons of legend, was able to breathe
fire.
Or, more accurately, the beast could expel
a vapour of methane from its mouth, and then
ignite this gas via unknown means.
Tharnock could speak at least seven languages,
and claimed it could mimic the form of any
human.
The contents of the dragon’s lair was estimated
to be worth almost 13.4 million United States
dollars, and it was learned that SCP-3844
would burrow underneath the treature when
it slept.
If those traits sound familiar, that’s because
they are all recurring ideas that feature
in the various legends of dragons from throughout
the ages.
In fact, SCP-3844 claimed to have been the
inspiration behind many European myths that
revolved around dragons.
It even asserted that it had been the model
for the Welsh flag, which depicts a red dragon
in its center.
From time to time, O5-2, would still visit
his old friend SCP-3844 for chats in the dragon’s
cave.
During one of their conversations, the dragon
and O5-2 discussed some of the many scientific
advancements human beings had made over the
years, which SCP-3844 learned about through
the reading material it had been provided.
“How long had you known about the nature
of light?”
SCP-3844 asked, to which Doctor Fegmont replied
“Decades at least.”
The dragon also asked about what it called
‘the inner workings of our smallest building
block’, and O5-2 explained that mankind
had split the atom during the second world
war.
SCP-3844 then asked if science could explain
his kind, expressing a longing to stretch
his wings again and leave the confines of
his cave.
O5-2 denied the dragon’s request, claiming
that advances in radar technology posed a
potential risk to SCP-3844 if it was allowed
to take flight again.
He offered to at least find a way to make
the dragon’s home bigger and more comfortable,
before he bid the creature farewell.
As they parted, both said that they hoped
to see each other again, which they would,
but only one final time.
When they met for what would be the last time,
O5-2 returned to the cave at SCP-3844’s
request.
The dragon was surprised to see that Lester
was still alive after so many years, and hadn’t
succumbed to old age and death the way most
humans do.
The doctor explained that as a member of the
O5 Council, he was kept in “pristine condition”
through thaumaturgy and temporal technology.
The dragon described it as magic, and O5-2
argued that everything in the world can be
explained with science if one examines for
long enough.
SCP-3844 agreed, although appeared defeated
by this admission.
It asked Lester to explain what he thought
the stars to be, and the doctor naturally
gave a scientific answer “Balls of flaming
gas.
If you want me to be more specific, I could
list their chemical components.”
The dragon was already aware of this thanks
to its reading material, but then asked “Do
you know what a duke once told me many, many
years ago when I asked him the same thing?
He said, ‘They're little lights from the
heavens.’
His voice spoke with awe, much like yours
when we first met.”
At first, O5-2 thought the creature was grieving
over the advancements humanity had made in
science, and how it had allowed them to better
understand the world.
But SCP-3844 grieved for the death of spectacle,
the death of the belief in miracles.
“I wish I could embrace science, but it
takes away so much of what I enjoy about this
world of ours,” the beast lamented, before
adding “It appears I'm allergic to the stuff.”
Learning about the world around it in such
detail had robbed SCP-3844 of its enjoyment
of the world.
Knowing everything could be explained by and
reduced to science saddened the dragon, losing
the wonder that comes from not knowing all
the answers.
With a heavy heart, the ancient creature proclaimed
it wanted to break the agreement it had made
with Doctor Fegmont all those years ago.
O5-2 tried to argue with the beast, to convince
the dragon to stay in its lair, but Tharnock
had not felt the wind beneath his wings in
over a hundred years, and longed to be with
others of his kind.
“You seem quite confident, '' O5-2 remarked
when the dragon announced its intention to
once again fly freely.
“Confidence is all I have left.
I don't want to believe that the world doesn't
need its whimsy anymore.”
Sadly, Tharnock’s flight was not to last.
As dictated by the Foundation’s Special
Containment Procedures, SCP-3844 was neutralized,
shot down by the anti-aircraft guns that were
positioned around its cavern.
The ancient, noble creature was no more, killed
for wanting to be free, for longing to believe
the world could still be a place filled with
wonder.
Curiously, the remains of the dragon that
the SCP Foundation recovered seemed to, in
actual fact, be those of a Draco Volans, a
non-anomalous species of lizard colloquially
known as the “Common Flying Dragon.”
These remains were kept under observation
by the Foundation’s research personnel,
and the cave where SCP-3844 had spent most
of its life was to be inspected every seventy
two hours for any signs of anomalous activity.
But somehow, through means still inexplicable
to the Foundation, the entrance to the cave
seemed to disappear almost entirely.
The area where SCP-3844 had been found and
was then kept prisoner no longer contained
a cavern.
The lair filled with riches, gems and valuables
had vanished.
In its place, was a small hole, and behind
it?
Dragons.
Ever since the death of Tharnock, the designation
of SCP-3844 has been reassigned, to a collection
of large, winged reptiles that reside deep
within a number of mountains all over the
world.
The SCP Foundation received multiple confirmed
reports of these creatures living in the Himalayas,
the Rockies, the Appalachians, the Andes and
the Dolomite Mountain ranges, where the very
first instance of SCP-3844 had been discovered,
all the way back in 1906.
Being the most familiar with Tharnock, O5-2
was assigned to investigate the sudden appearance
of these creatures, and tasked with the challenge
of containing them.
Tharnock had been slain, killed by the Foundation
for wanting nothing more than to be free in
a world of wonder and intrigue.
However, one thing seemed clear, he was not
the only one of his kind.
Rest assured and don’t mourn too much for
Tharnock, there are still dragons living in
the mountains.
Now go check out “SCP-1762 - Where The Dragons
Went” and “SCP-348 - A Gift from Dad”
for more SCPs that’ll bring a tear to your
eye!